hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing a horrific
Harry Potter theory that bears the
potential to completely flip the Harry
Potter ending on its head it involves
you guessed it our main antagonist Lord
Voldemort and a scenario in which
Voldemort
survives Voldemort is defeated at least
markedly twice in the Harry Potter story
his first defeat was at the potter
residence in godrick's Hollow where his
rebounding curse thanks to Lily's loving
sacrifice shot back at him and ripped
his soul from his destroyed body this
marked the temporary end of Voldemort
and the end of the first Wizarding War
but Voldemort certainly wasn't done oh
no no in 1995 Voldemort made his
Resurgence more motivated than ever to
take back control of the Wizarding World
and get revenge on the boy who had
defeated him however this didn't work
out too well for him either as shown in
his final showdown with Harry during the
Battle of Hogwarts Tom Riddle hit the
floor with a mundane finality his body
feeble and shrunken the white hands
empty the snake-like face vacant and
unknowing Voldemort was dead killed by
his unrebounding curse and Harry stood
with two ones in his hand staring down
at his enemy's shell and after this
final fated Jewel it's generally
accepted that Voldemort was dead in the
films Voldemort's body broke off into
thousands of pieces and vanished into
nothing and in the books the former dark
lord was reduced to a corpse just like
anyone else it's ironic that Voldemort
who also viewed death dying as pure
weakness a fate reserved for the
unimportant and Powerless would end up
as a corpse just like everyone else
thrown into a pile of other bodies in
the chamber off the Great Hall they
moved Voldemort body and laid it in the
chamber of the hall away from the bodies
of Fred Tonks Lupine Colin creevy and 50
others who died fighting him eventually
after all of the Dust has settled
Voldemort's body is moved into a resting
chamber within the walls of Hogwarts
something that the films failed to
mention altogether it's here somewhere
entirely unspecified within the castle
that Voldemort purportedly lay for the
remainder of Eternity or did he the
theory that I want to put forth today
suggests that Voldemort by way of you
guessed it poor cruxes once able to
survive horcruxes are as most of you
will know an object in which a dark
witch or wizard has imbued part of their
soul the purpose of doing this is to
make it difficult for the witch or
wizard to be completely killed achieving
in a sense some form of immortality each
horcrux ties a piece of the individual's
soul to the Mortal realm grounding it
and in Voldemort's case he happened to
create many of these life-preserving
objects by the end of the story
Voldemort's presumably out of horcruxes
which is why Harry was able to kill him
however today we're going to explore the
possibility that Voldemort may have
actually had one last stake in the
Mortal realm that was overlooked some
fans have speculated that the soul of
Lord Voldemort was not fully destroyed
when Harry defeated him at the end of
the series instead it is suggested that
a piece of Voldemort's Soul remained
hidden within Harry waiting for the
opportunity to take over his body and
regenerate we know that for most of the
books and films Harry carried a piece of
Voldemort's soul with him that is until
his Showdown with Voldemort in the
Forbidden Forest
Voldemort had raised his wand his head
was still tilted to one side like a
curious child wondering what would
happen if he proceeded Harry looked back
into the red eyes and wanted it to
happen now quickly while he could still
stand before he lost control before he
betrayed fear he saw the mouth move in a
flash of green light and everything was
gone at this point Harry wakes up in a
sort of limbo where he's given the
option of returning to the land for
living or moving on the prevailing
argument for why Harry has this option
is because he wasn't killed but merely
the Peace of Voldemort inside of him
Voldemort had foolishly rebuilt his body
using Harry Potter's blood which meant
that both of them were protected by
Lily's loving sacrifice Dumbledore
confirms this he took your blood and
rebuilt his living body with it your
blood in his veins Harry Lily's
protection inside both of you he
tethered you to life while he lives
essentially because Harry's soul is now
whole and pure he is given the
opportunity to return to his life as
just Harry all he has to do at this
point is choose to go back however I
have an issue with this the method by
which Voldemort chose to kill Harry was
via Avada Kedavra which many have
speculated Kills You by magically
ripping the soul from the body at this
point soul is separated from body with
your body remaining in the Mortal plane
and your soul moving on from here you'll
end up in one of three places back on
Earth as a ghost assuming you have
unfinished business limbo where Harry
makes his choice to return or The
Wizarding afterlife the afterlife in
Harry Potter is never clearly defined
but what is clear is that it's the best
place you can go upon dying an idyllic
Place akin to a state of Nirvana if you
want a full explanation of what happens
then check out my video what happens to
wizards when they die The Wizarding
afterlife explained if it was indeed the
piece of Voldemort's Soul fragment that
was destroyed by his killing curse and
not Harry's own soul then why was
Harry's Soul sent to Limbo by my logic
arrow is still protected by the blood
that he and Voldemort shared so it
stands to reason that there's no
rational explanation for why Harry's
Soul would have been sent off to limbo
along with the piece of Voldemort's Soul
the argument that I want to make here is
that Voldemort's Soul fragment inside of
Harry was never destroyed when hit via
Voldemort's killing curse in the
Forbidden Forest the spell had the
desired effect it ripped Harry's soul
from his body but because of him being
tied to the Mortal realm via blood he of
course had the option to come back
okay so now you might be asking but what
about the mutilated baby-like creature
that Harry sees in limbo wasn't that
supposed to be representative of
Voldemort's newly destroyed Soul
fragment the same piece that resided in
Harry Harry turned slowly on the spot
and his surroundings seemed to invent
themselves before his eyes he had
spotted the thing that was making the
noises it had the form of a small naked
child curled on the ground its skin raw
and rough flayed looking and it lays
shuddering and receipt where it had been
left unwanted stuffed out of sight
struggling for breath
most fans believe that the child on the
floor of King's cross was in fact the
part of Voldemort's soul that previously
resided within Harry after all Harry
carried a piece of Voldemort with him
for his entire life and so it seems to
make sense that with Harry dying and the
Soul Shard now destroyed it would follow
him to the afterlife however though this
is close to the answer it's actually
wrong according to JK Rowling the being
stuck in limbo with Harry was actually
just a representation of the current
state of Voldemort's Soul what exactly
was he mutilated baby-like creature
Harry saw King's cross in chapter 35 of
Hallows I've been asked this a lot it is
the last piece of Soul Voldemort
possesses when Voldemort attacks Harry
they both fall temporarily unconscious
and both their souls Harry's undamaged
and healthy Voldemort stunted and maimed
appear in the limbo where Harry meets
Dumbledore if both Harry and Voldemort's
souls are accounted for in limbo then
where is the soul fragment in Harry That
was supposed to have been newly
destroyed I think it lived on inside of
Harry Voldemort may have been defeated
at the end of the battle of Hogwarts but
it certainly wasn't the first time he'd
been defeated to such an observable
extent and it absolutely doesn't mean
that he had necessarily exhausted all
options with regards to his return to
the Mortal realm with the Voldemort's
apparent defeat The Wizarding World was
able to finally exercise a collective
sigh of relief Hogwarts was rebuilt the
ministry of magic was restructured
Diagon Alley returned to its prosperous
former State and most importantly Harry
was able to grow up in the very normal
life but Hazard gets dark I think that
as Harry Grew Older and more powerful
the parasitic Soul fragment inside of
him laid dormant biding its time and
conserving its energy for the day that
it would strike entirely unknown to
Harry this piece of Voldemort's Soul was
still latched on to him sucking away
undetectable amounts of energy learning
from him and most importantly plotting
its return
I'm of the impression that on one dark
day the parasite inside of Harry became
powerful enough to control his body
leading to the indirect Rebirth of Lord
Voldemort through Harry using him as a
vessel in the same way that he used
Quirrell just to a greater extent this
Theory unsettling as it is challenges
the happy ending of the Harry Potter
series and poses the idea that the
apparent Harmony in The Wizarding World
after Voldemort's demise is not as
permanent as it may have seemed
according to this Theory darkness and
evil may always be lurking in the
shadows waiting for the opportunity to
resurface and that's it for this video
what do you guys think of this theory is
it plausible if I missed something
obvious here if I have please let me
know I will be the first to admit that
it's far-fetched but it's always
interesting to imagine a different
outcome to the story that we all know
and love let me know what you think of
the comment section down below and be
sure to like the video and subscribe to
the channel to support future content
until next time remember it is the
unknown We Fear when we look upon death
and darkness nothing more